hey y'all it's andrew couch here and
this tire tuesday video we're gonna be
forecasting the us election
it is a presidential election year
and we will be voting um basically next
week
on tuesday so um i would highly
encourage you guys to
you know turn out and vote um
a little um background for me is how i
actually got
into data and statistics was through
politics
so in high school i was taking a stats
class so
we were doing a lot of uh studying like
p values and confidence intervals
and this was during basically the 2016
election too so
i was interested in basically reading
polling data and that's kind of
how i got into data science um i
actually was for
uh following mostly uh 538's forecasts
which they have a nice little page
showing their own forecast for this
presidential election
but what's really cool about the
economists is they have
all of their models on their github repo
so it's
public information um i wanted to make
a model from scratch in stan and doing
some
um adjustments while i thought what the
model should have been done
specifically with like how they uh
address like fatter tails and dealing
with correlation between states
but uh i think that's a little out of
the scope for this
video and it would take a decent amount
of time and i wanted to get a video
about election modeling uh before the
election
so luckily elliot morris who is
basically kind of like
one of the main people behind the the
economist's
uh forecast he has a election simulator
um in his own repo which will basically
simulate error with the polls and then
use that
um pull results to output some um
some results for each states and then
you do some simulations through it
um i will also say i really like the
economist's uh
forecasts andrew gellman
or gillum he
is also a person who worked on this
forecast and
um andrew is definitely kind of like the
godfather of modern
basing statistics who i think he helped
write stan
and all those um cool bayesian models
uh modeling languages so i thought it'd
be cool to make this uh video on the
election forecast
so i basically we're not gonna be
rewriting this entire thing so
i basically copy and paste it into a our
markdown
file and i thought it'd be interesting
to just kind of explain what this
polling simulator is doing okay so first
we have all this data where it's
essentially reading in polling data
some results from the election um some
coefficients from the states
um state electoral vote results etc
so we're going to load that in i'm also
going to load in these packages the main
packages we're going to be using
is mostly the tidy verse and gl net
so gl net and carrot um are
you know the previous ml packages but
they use carrot because
um we can actually use do some more
things that tidy models cannot do
so once we load in our data which
basically just has our pulling data
our state results um some weights that
they calculated using our state results
from like the national vote
um so it's nothing too crazy
um we also have like the electoral votes
for each state
and then i had this thing called
parameters so these are the parameters
um that will be entering into our
simulation
most of it is just like you know when
did we run this um standard
deviation and then they kind of
calculate the standard deviations that
we're going to be applying to our
uh simulator we also have like a num
cores which will detect
uh the amount of chords we have in our
computer it doesn't do crazy
so the data ringing part is kind of the
main thing
and we're really just trying to extract
um
some some um ideas about the polls
so we have our days till election our
start date
and it's essentially just applying this
and giving some weights to our
observations for our pulls
so you can see right here it just does
some basic filtering it's saying that
we want poles that are before
our run date for this model which is
today just some basic
uh data munching converting the date to
a month to your
month day year i'm removing any uh
missing values for binary trump uh polls
and then it gives away based off the
number of observations
okay so if they have a lot of
uh a lot of people i'm gonna be heavily
weighted
which is good for uh polls generally you
want more people
then we had this thing that basically
averages the polls out
so it has this uh decay on it
um and it's basically just kind of uh
going through it
kind of doing a sliding window and
averaging out the pull results and then
extracting the
the average margin so what applies this
actual averaging out
um into a national poll average
then just filter some dates um again
calculate state averages nothing too
crazy it does calculate a margin
based off their on polling differences
and then we have a decayed wait which is
you know the days till
our run date then summaries it all up
you know counts the number of polls
averages the margin gets the weights
okay so then we have all our results
from our 2016 election
nothing too crazy um
we have a some polls too where it's like
our average
uh what's the average margin for each
poll
um the weights uh the the lien for each
state so it's saying that if clinton
you know won this uh say let's say if
clinton won
michigan then it would wait the uh
the lean towards it from the previous
elections
so nothing too crazy i'm just a little
bit more tactical and more intuition if
you know
like some poli sci and know about
polling and
what happened in the elections so the
one of the big things is it actually
uses a stepwise linear model
um so it's essentially using these
variables
um making a model um removing it
and calculating like the aic scores and
then figure out which one has the best
score for that
uh i don't i'm pretty sure it's
backwards or it might be step uh
uh forward but i'm pretty sure it's
backwards um
so it does that um with to basically
estimate
the coefficients for like percentiles of
of
your demographics so those will be kind
of our weights for our demographics
okay then it has a test set where it's
doing the same thing
this is training a gl net model
using um the the pulling data
lastly it basically you predicts
the margin using these demographic
effects
and then it takes the average between a
you know
a stepwise gl net model and then a
regular gm net model
and it pulls that prediction okay
so once it does that it essentially just
uh creates some weights
we have the component of the partisan
way and then it takes a pred so it's
saying like we're going to take
our our margin multiply it by our way
and then we're going to add this type of
little
um um lean based margin times personal
weight so it's basically trying to
measure
um like how republican or how a
democratic estate is as a prior
then it's going to make some projections
right here so it's just going to assign
our pred
to this other typical
it's going to average out our state um
pulling it's going to do a slight
adjustment to it
by taking out the average and then it's
gonna
apply a weighted mean to it
now it's gonna basically just uh what
this uh function does it'll basically um
try to convert some of the state um
values to the national or to the united
states
average which is not too crazy it uses
some optimization to figure out the best
way to do it
um so like the best way to add
to shift it um let's see what else does
do
saves the margin and then finally it
just combines them together
until we have this data set uh now we're
actually going to reach the simulation
so if you saw our prior stuff it's
essentially just
calculating and estimating weights um to
add and also how we can shift these
polling data
to say like a national margin which is
pretty useful and it's pretty
uh it's something what a lot of
pollsters will do anyways and it's
something that
is pretty straightforward obviously um
they put a lot of thought into it
but um the general idea and intuition is
is pretty simple to get what they're
trying to do
then what they're gonna do is basically
simulate
the errors for all the polls so we have
like national airport
uh regional error and state error
and now we're actually going to reach
the simulation part so the simulation
part is
it's essentially going to say that we
have a certain amount of simulations
we're going to assume our national error
is zero
and then we're going to give it our
national error as our standard deviation
and
repeat that many times for however many
simulations we want
so it's going to do that for all three
um hierarchies national regional and
state
and then what it's going to do is it's
essentially going to um take
those um simulated errors and then uh
basically join them with our st are our
polling data so once it does that
uh it's going to basically uh join them
together so it's going to join the
errors and it's going to add the errors
to the margins
then it's going to take out all of the
simulations or errors and then it's
going to summarize it
lastly i actually created a function
that'll that basically uses
the past stuff so we can feed it in
a range of national errors so if we want
to
if we're saying that uh we think that
our state errors are going to be
um off by more than just .03 for the
standard deviation
we can we're able to pass in a list of
errors so
i could say okay maybe i so if i uh pass
in like .01 instead of 0.03 we're saying
that
uh state errors will not be as bad and
it'll probably be closer to be more
accurate
or we can give it 0.05 which was which
is basically assuming that state error
will be more inaccurate okay
so that's pretty much it um i'm gonna
i think i might run this but i'm just
gonna run it it's a pretty fast
uh um pretty fast script so i'm just
going to
do that i'm going to let it go
and we're going to let it run
okay right now it's training up the
model
it's going through it
okay cool so now we ran that it was
pretty fast
and what we can look at is um right here
i essentially um x calculated actually
we just go through it so essentially i
just did on this part i'm trying to
figure out
um the essentially the electoral votes
per state
so what i'm saying is if the state
margin
is greater than zero then we assume that
biden want it else
uh trump on it we do a pivot wider so
now we have basically like a one hot
encoded
state margin so for arkansas
um our total individual state votes is
three whereas binary lost that say so
it's zero
i group by the draw which is essentially
a simulation and i basically uh
summarize all that stuff up
so essentially what we're saying is for
each simulation what other total
electoral votes
each candidate received okay and then i
do some conditions so
if uh if the
trump state is zero that means biden
want it else trump on it
um same thing with the election so i'm
saying if
uh uh if biden
got at least 270 electoral votes then
buy and want it
okay i then selected this stuff so i'm
just saying like
for this simulation uh for arkansas
trump won the state but in the actual
simulation biden won the election
i did a group by for each state and then
counted
um each individual component
i then uh computed the proportion for
each conditional state and i ungrouped
it
and what i'm basically trying to figure
out is say for example florida which is
uh generally considered as a tipping
point state is
um what's the probability of biden
winning the election
if he's won the state okay so in all the
simulations we've
basically counted out all the outcomes
whether trump or bayern won the state
and whether
trump or biden won the election and we
also have the crosstabs of it
so in this example we can see that if
biden wins
florida biden has an 89
chance of winning the election as you
can see with trump if trump were to win
the state
then trump would still have a very low
chance of winning the election
and that's because this is a polling
based model
with no other um prior effects so we
don't have any like
incumbent effects we don't have any um
autocorrelation effects etc
etc so what we can also look at is just
basically just the
actual um electoral votes so let's go
back here and i'm just gonna
um grab that and we can do this
so with um we can just uh what's here
we can we select the
uh draw trump uh
national and then biden
national and then we can just kind of
we can just do a was it a a pivot
longer minus draw
and then we can g plot the results out
so x equals value uh color
equals name and then we do a geom like
uh density
okay and then we can see how with the
electoral votes ooh actually we can do a
uh
we see what this simulation we give
biden uh most time buying will win this
election in fact
in the uh lower entails um we would have
to see a
an anomaly basically or um for buying to
lose
all right so um we can do one more thing
um
we can kind of look at all of the
conditional probabilities of each state
so we can do that and then we can say we
can figure out what are the more
important states for each candidate so
let's say filter
one election is equal to biden
okay and then we can see like arrange
one state
so now we can see what are the states um
that result into biden winning so we can
then arrange it
by prob uh descending improv
so we see most of these states we expect
finance to win it um
we can allow say like west virginia and
uh wyoming for
trump to win but let's look at say the
the main states that we would expect so
in this case we would say filter
let's say state
is nc florida
iowa ohio pennsylvania
right and now we can say arrange by uh
descending order and prob
okay so right here we can see that
generally
biden will always have the highest
probability of winning the election
in in reality what by what trump really
needs to do
is he needs to win ohio and florida
because if we do a another filter say
filter
one election is equal to trump
we see the states are basically
imperative for him to win
are ohio and florida you know iowa
so trump will need to win these three
states to actually win the election
okay let's do one more
brief look at our stuff and just say
um we can say like uh for buying
let's look at what are the states that
he can lose
so juan state is equal to trump
that he can like uh be fine with and
then one election
is equal to i didn't so i'm saying we
are we
are only keeping the states we're buying
and wins the election
and then we also want to figure out the
states that um
trump won okay and
maybe we can just say range by
descending over and improv
okay so what we can do basically is
allow
trump to win west virginia wyoming
oklahoma north dakota kentucky
was it was it arizona arizona
idaho alabama uh south dakota
so we can see that this is pretty um
this is what we would expect for it
right obviously there's gonna be some
weird tales where
you know we're fine with trump winning
illinois when in reality it is
unrealistic for
trump to win illinois but since we're
doing simulations we can allow these
one-time anomalies
i know this is a pretty quick video but
i thought this was a pretty interesting
uh
um github repo so i wanted to share it
to you guys i will also be posting
on this file with all the data so you
guys can mess with it yourself i think
an interesting project would be maybe
making a shiny dashboard
using the simulations but um i'll see
you guys next week
make sure to vote and tidy on